this is coffee this is coffee being  poured into the most iconic cup in new  york city history so how did they sell  over a billion of these  [Music]  this is leslie buck a holocaust survivor  immigrating to new york after world war  ii he got a job working as a sales  manager at the sherry cup company the  company wanted to break into the new  york diner scene leslie noticed greeks  ran most of the diners so what did he do  he decided to create and design a cup  that would appeal to them use the colors  of the greek flag blue and white along  the top is a greek key one of the most  iconic designs in architecture the sides  mimic a grecian vase smack dab in the  middle greek style lettering that  embodied the very soul and motto of the  cup we are happy to serve you  and guess what it worked solo bought the  sherry cup company in 1994 alone they  sold over 500 million cups and today the  m4a cup has reached full-blown icon  status  nice work guys  [Music]  you